The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK,
settle down.
It's time to start learning.
One announcement.
Tomorrow we'll have
the weekly quiz.
In lieu of the Tuesday
celebration, we're going to
move to Thursday, since the
holiday moved everything,
compressed the week.
So last day, we were talking
about doping of
semiconductors, and I want
to finish up that unit.
Just to refresh your memory,
we looked at how we could
change the behavior of the
semiconductor by introducing
impurity atoms. And when the
behavior of the semiconductor
is dominated by the impurity
atoms, we term
that behavior extrinsic.
In other words, it's not the
behavior of silicon itself,
but it's the behavior of silicon
as determined by the
presence of some dopant atom.
And we looked at the special
case of doping with a
supervalent impurity.
And here's the energy level
diagram for that situation,
where we've got the valence
band down here, we've got
conduction band up here,
separated by an energy gap.
That's all characteristic of
plain vanilla silicon.
But then when we dope with the
supervalent impurity, there is
an extra electron.
And that is put into a donor
level that lies just a tiny
bit below the bottom of
the conduction band.
And then, thanks to thermal
excitation, which gives us an
average energy of about 1/40 of
an electron bolt, we get,
for all intents and purposes,
100% excitation of the
electronics that sit in the
donor level, excitation up
into the conduction band.
And this is what electrical
engineers term ionization.
And I also reminded you last
day that this is the donor
level, and for each donor atom,
there sits a donor level
at the same value of energy,
but these are so far apart
point, owing to the dilution,
the dilute concentration of
the impurity, that we
don't violate the
Pauli Exclusion Principle.
So these are all sitting at the
same level and that's why
they've given temperature
promotes all of them up into
the conduction band, where
they are mobile.
And then, just to complete the
review, we call this n-type
because, thanks to doping, we
generate electrons in the
conduction band, and electrons
are negative.
Supervalent doping
gives us n-type.
Then the total number of
electrons in the conduction
band is the sum of those that
would have been generated by
plain old thermal excitation.
Thermal excitation operates
all the time.
So with thermal excitation,
recall, we promote from the
valence band up into the
conduction band.
So we break one of these bonds,
shoot an electron up
here, and leave a hole behind.
So this generates the pair.
Hole in the valence band,
and electron in
the conduction band.
That's always operative, but
owing to the energies
involved, the band gap is on
the order of one electron
volt, whereas the donor level
sits only about 1/50 of an
electron volt below the
conduction band.
So we get very, very little
promotion at room temperature.
And in fact, it's something like
10 to the minus 19 is the
fraction of promotion, and if
you say roughly 10 to the
twenty-third per cubic
centimeter, that means you've
got about 10 to the fourth
electrons per cubic centimeter
due to this thermal excitation
from the valence band to the
conduction band.
Normally, when you dope a
semiconductor, you dope it
around parts per
million level.
And parts per million, that's
10 to the minus 6.
If you take 10 to the minus 6
times 10 to the 23, you get
about 10 of the 17.
Now you can see, 10 of the 17
is vastly larger than 10 of
the fourth.
So for all intents and purposes,
once you've doped
something, this contribution is
essentially 0, and so the
electron population, the
conduction band, is that
dictated by the impurity atoms,
which is why we say
that this is exhibiting
extrinsic behavior.
The intrinsic properties
are not
visible, they're not palpable.
They're immeasurable.
So intrinsic is substantially
less than extrinsic.
Now, the last thing I wanted
to do for you before we say
goodbye to this fascinating
topic, which lays the
groundwork for everything that
we know in the modern
electronic era, parenthetically,
is to look at
the other type of doping.
I've showed you how to make
an n-type semiconductor.
How do we make a p-type
semiconductor?
So in that case, what
we can do is dope
with a subvalent impurity.
What do I mean by subvalent?
Well, the valency of silicon
is 4, so I want
something less than 4.
So a good example is
boron into silicon.
So boron is group 13, or 3, all
right, if you look on your
periodic table.
And silicon is group
14, according
to the IUPAC notation.
So let's go back and take a look
at how that might appear.
So I'm going to draw the
silicon crystal.
Remember, this is going into a
single crystal of silicon.
So silicon is sp 3 hybridized,
and we have silicons
everywhere in the structure.
So we're going to
put silicons.
And I'm trying to show
sp 3 hybridization.
So this is 3 legs each in the
plane, then you've got 109
degrees here.
So that's silicon, and so on.
I get the three of them
just to complete
enough of the picture.
And now what we're going to
do, is introduced boron.
And boron goes into the
silicon lattice
and covalently bonds.
It doesn't go sit in some void
space in between the silicons.
It actually sits on
a silicon site and
substitutes for the silicon.
Now, boron is group 13.
It's got 3 valence electrons.
And so it forms bonds
with 3 silicons.
And now there's a fourth silicon
here, and that silicon
has an electron, but
the boron doesn't
have a fourth electron.
Here's where it gets
interesting.
The driving force to complete
the picture here is so great
that the system will actually
pull an electron out of a
silicon-silicon bond--
and so I'm going to use a
different color chalk, and I'm
going to indicate, just for
argument's sake, that we're
going to pull an electron out of
this bond here, break this
bond, and shoot that electron
over to here.
That way, we get r months
around the boron.
It says p3 hybridized.
It just doesn't have that
extra electron.
But now it rips the electron
out of this
silicon-silicon bond.
And what's the consequence
of breaking this bod?
What's the electrical feature
that we've created here?
A hole.
So now we've created a hole
somewhere else in the crystal
in order to satisfy the
desire of boron to
get that fourth bond.
And now can you see that for
every boron that I introduced
into the crystal, I'm
going to make a hole
somewhere in the crystal.
And on the energy level
diagram, where
do those holes live?
Those holes live in
the valence band.
So let's go make the energy
level diagram.
So up here we have the
conduction band, and
downstairs, we have the valence
band, as before.
And I'm going to assume that we
got the thermal promotion.
But it's so tiny in comparison
to the amount of boron we're
going to put in.
I'm not going to muddy the
water here and show that
you've got pair formation.
Because the extent of it is so
small, it doesn't make any
difference.
So now what happens?
Now, I know I'm going to
generate holes here, and I've
got to show this energy level.
And this bonding level
is different from
this bonding level.
Agree?
Silicon-silicon bond has
different bond energy from
boron-silicon bond.
So that means the top
of the valence band
is different from--
because this valence band is
silicon-silicon-silicon.
So it turns out that, and this
is not to scale, that the
energy level of this bond is
just a little bit higher.
And this is an energy level that
involves the accepting of
electrons, whereas in
the other case, we
were donating electrons.
Hence, that's called
the donor level.
This is called the
acceptor level.
And it's about 1/50 of an
electron volt above the top of
the valence band.
And so what happens is that in
order to make this bond, we
move something out of the
valence band up into the
acceptor level and
generate a hole.
And so for every boron that
we put in, we have
another broken bond.
And all of these lie at the same
level, but the dilution
is so high, that they're so
far apart, that they don't
violate the polyexplosion
principle.
They're thermally promoted
up, and away we go.
So now, under these
circumstances, the number of
negative charge carriers no
longer equals the number of
positive charge carriers.
Because I've got all these
Thanks to the introduction of
boron, p is greater than n.
So we've made a p-type
semiconductor, by the
introduction of a subvalent
impurity.
And we can redo the entire
central part of last day's
lesson, which was
the Bohr model.
Now, this is the sexiest
part of the Bohr
model I've ever seen.
This is really, really cool.
The hole is mobile!
And the boron is a little bit
shy of protons, right?
It's 3 in a land of 4.
So it's negative.
So I've got a stationary
negative center, and I've got
something positive revolving
around a negative center.
This is an inverse Bohr model!
Because the Bohr model has a
honking big positive center
with a dinky little electron
revolving around.
We've got the immobile negative
center, and the
mobile hole revolving around.
Go through, you get the
same set of quantum--
I mean, there's a whole bunch
of quantum levels in here.
Fantastic!
How far that Bohr model
can take us.
So now you know how to make a
p-type semiconductor, you know
how to make an n-type
semiconductor.
And then what you can do
is put them together.
And you can put, say,
boron-doped silicon opposite
phosphorus-doped silicon.
Be careful here.
The fonts are really critical.
This is uppercase P,
for phosphorus.
This is lowercase p, for
positive doping.
So don't go, oh, P, phosphorus,
that means it's p-type.
No, P gives you extra
electrons.
It's n-type.
So that's what uppercase P.
This is a lowercase p.
This is p-type.
So now I've got p-type,
n-type, and so
what do I have here?
I've got a p-n junction.
And this is the beginning
of solid state devices,
rectification of A/C current,
diodes, you name it.
And it all starts with
this, the chemistry.
This is the birth of the
transistor, and all the modern
electronics that we have
based on that.
Later on, we'll show you how you
get the boron in, and how
you get the phosphorus in.
You don't just come in and
sprinkle it on top, and hope
that it goes to the
lattice site.
There's a lot of processing
involved.
OK.
So this is where I want to
hold for the unit on
semiconductors, and how
it fits into the
grand scheme of things.
So in the books, you'll see--
this is a very crude drawing,
because this is showing n-type
semiconductor with grossly
exaggerated numbers of donor
electronics up here.
There's no mention of
the donor level.
So this is sort of
semiconductivity, sort of pre-3091.
This is extrinsic semiconduction
for idiots, I
guess you'd call it.
And then, same thing here.
You see all of the holes
in the valence band.
We know better, because we know
there's an acceptor level
and there's a donor level.
OK.
So now we're going
to switch gears.
Now here's the big transition,
right now.
If the last two lectures didn't
leave high school
behind, today we leave
high school behind.
So those of you who have been
coasting up until now, thanks
to your very good high
school background,
start paying attention.
Because it's high
school no more.
So just to remind you
where we've come.
We started over here, at the
beginning of the semester.
And the big theme is going to
be, electronic structure
informs bonding, which informs
state of aggregation.
State of aggregation is
solid, liquid, or gas.
So I want to show you how
we get to where we are.
So we did all of these
topics, right?
Bohr, or Sommerfeld quantum
numbers, multielectron.
And then we came to
octet stability.
And with octet stability,
we went a long way.
We got into ionic bonding.
We got into completing
the valence shell.
And in fact, all of this
is a consequence
of the octet stability.
And that led us into
the various
types of primary bonding.
Ionic, covalent, metallic.
And in some instances,
van der Waals.
Solid argon is van
der Waals bond.
It's the only kind of bonding,
so it's the primary bonding.
But in some cases, like HCl,
how do you get liquid HCl?
How do you get solid methane?
So we had invoke secondary
bonding for some of these
covalent molecules, and that
invoked dipole-dipole
interaction, the London
dispersion force, which is the
same as the van der Walls bond,
but I decided to mix
things up, so that both men get
a little bit of attention,
none of them feel slighted.
And finally, hydrogen bonding,
in those special instances.
And that allowed us to then
determine whether something
was a gas, a liquid,
or a solid.
And when it's a solid,
we're happy.
Because this is 3091,
and we're interested
in the solid state.
By the way, what is a solid?
Well, here's an operative
definition.
That which is dimensionally
stable, has a
volume of its own.
It doesn't distort in
a gravity field.
All right?
Liquids will distort.
Fluids, gases will distort.
Now, there's two ways of
classifying solids.
One is bonding type.
That's what we did here.
But the second way of
classifying solids is based on
atomic arrangements.
All right?
So let's look at that.
There's only two types of
atomic arrangement.
Ordered and disordered.
I love these taxonomies
that split everything
into a choice of 2.
That way, you just sort of go
through life and decide, is it
left or is it right?
Is it up or is it down?
Is it ordered or is
it disordered?
So what are the characteristics
or an ordered solid?
It has a regular atomic
arrangement.
That means it's got a
long-range order.
And I'll show you that in an
ordered solid, I know not only
where my next nearest neighbor
is, where my tenth nearest
neighbor is.
I know where my hundred and
fifty second nearest neighbor
is, because it's an
ordered solid.
And we have a simple Anglo-Saxon
word for an
ordered solid.
It's called crystal.
So when I say something is a
metallic crystal, I don't mean
it's something that's got
magical properties, and if I
put it over my head, I get
powerful or something.
It just means I've got atoms
in an atomic regular
arrangement.
Now contrasting to that
is a disordered solid.
And in that case, we have
a random arrangement.
But I put an asterisk here
because, as they say in
California, it's not
totally random.
It's only random
up to a point.
No long-range order.
There may be short-range
order.
In other words, I know what my
next nearest neighbor is, but
I probably don't know where my
tenth nearest neighbor is
Because the coordination shell
is established, but the next
coordination shell, and the
next coordination shell,
they're not established.
And I'm going to show you, with
examples, what that means
So we call those kinds of
disordered solids amorphous
solids, as opposed to the
regular solids, which are
crystalline solids.
And there's a plain Anglo-Saxon
word for a
disordered solid.
It's glass.
Now you might think, well, gee,
doesn't glass mean that
it's transparent in
visible light?
No, no.
Maybe up until now, but I want
everybody who's ever taken
3091 from me to be disabused of
the notion that glass means
transparent.
How do we think about the
question of transparency?
And here I mean transparency
vis-a-vis visible light.
I'm not going to say, what's
transparent to x-rays?
That's pedantry.
So how do we think about
whether something is
transparent to visible light?
We just ask ourselves, is the
band gap greater than 3
electron volts?
The band gap is greater than 3
electron volts, visible light
zooms right through.
It doesn't have enough energy
to excite the electrons, be
absorbed, and re-emit.
So that's what transparency
means.
So I can have the kind of
material that's used in things
like eyeglasses.
It's transparent to visible
light because of
its high band gap.
Diamond, diamond is transparent
to visible light,
and you wouldn't dare insult
diamond by saying
that diamond is glass!
In fact, watch the old gangster
movies from the
1930s, that was the derogatory
term for fake diamonds.
You call them glass.
So how is it that diamond, which
is crystalline, it's
transparent to visible light,
and yet the window glass that
we have is transparent
to visible light?
It has nothing to do with
state of order.
Has everything to
do with this.
In fact, David, if we could
shoot to the document camera,
I'll show you a piece of glass
that's not transparent to
visible light.
How do we zoom in
on this thing?
OK.
Auto focus.
So what I'm showing you is
a piece of obsidian.
It's a naturally occurring
mineral.
It's rich in silica, and it's
turned dark because it's got
some iron impurity, and the iron
absorbs in the visible.
And this is clearly not
transparent to visible light,
and yet, it is a disordered
solid.
This is a glassy solid.
In fact, the white
speckles there
are devitrified obsidian.
It's actually started
to crystallize.
So the crystalline form is the
part that's transparent.
If you could peel off this
crystalline form, you'd
actually end up with
something that's
transparent to visible light.
So here's an example of where
the crystalline form is
transparent to visible light,
and the glassy form is opaque.
So glass has nothing to
do with transparency.
This is how you think about the
question of transparency.
OK.
So let's cut back to the
slides, David, please.
So we're now going to start by
looking at ordered solids.
So we're going to take next
several lessons and talk about
ordered solids, and then after
that, we're going to take a
few more lessons and talk
about distorted solids.
Now first of all, what's
the term crystal?
Where does it come from?
It comes from the Greek word,
crystallus, which is the Greek
word for ice.
That's where we get
the term crystal.
So we're going to start
with a history lesson.
That's how we start everything
in 3091.
A history lesson.
So we go way, way back to
Isaac Newton's time.
The Reformation, Charles, Oliver
Cromwell, all those
exciting times.
In merry old England, there
was Robert Hook.
You know him from Hook's
Law, in mechanics.
So he was doing military
research in 1660.
He was trying to understand what
was the optimal way to
stack cannon balls.
So when you're on a battle
front, you want to figure out
how to keep your material
compactly arranged.
You don't lie them
on the ground.
So from that, he concluded that
crystal that is a regular
array must owe its shape
to the packing
of spherical particles.
So that's what he was thinking,
or trying to imagine.
Remember, Democritus said that
we have these indivisible
particles, but no one had
ever seen them before.
Then in 1669, a Dane by the
name of Steenson who was
working in Italy was looking
at quartz crystals.
And he was studying various
quartz crystals.
By that I mean, quartz crystals
of different sizes.
And what he observed was, didn't
matter what the size of
the crystal was.
They always had the same
angles between
corresponding faces.
So if I give you a big crystal
and a smaller crystal of the
same material, and a smaller
crystal, and they all have the
same shape, Can you imagine that
you might conclude that
that is reflective of something
down at the atomic
level, and if you could get down
to the atomic level, that
spacial arrangement would
hold right now?
Because that's how
it grew, right?
It started from a small number
of atoms and grew, grew, grew.
Why would it start with one
shape, and all of a sudden
change to another shape?
It doesn't make any sense.
At least, not to me.
And certainly not to Steenson.
And then we go to
Holland, 1690.
Christiaan Huygens.
And he was studying
calcite crystals.
And he drew drawings of atomic
packing and bulk shape.
This is 1960.
I'm going ot show you an
image from his book.
This was drawn in 1690.
See, this is stacking of
cannonballs, but he was
looking at a calcite crystal.
Actually, Dave, could we cut
back to the document camera?
We're going to do a
fair bit of this.
I'll show you calcite crystal.
This is what he had
to work with.
It looks like this.
To give you a sense of scale--
what do I have?
Do I have anything
you'd recognize?
OK, here's a soda can to give
you a sense of scale, OK?
This is one honking big
calcite crystal.
I got it as a gift from someone
who watched 3091
lectures on OpenCourseWare.
And he said, if I ever
come to town, can
I attend your lecture?
I said, sure.
And he showed up, he attended
the lecture.
He was a man probably in his
early 40s, and as a pastime he
collects gemstones.
And he gave me this giant
calcite crystal, because the
one I was using before
was so pathetic.
He said, I've got
to give you one.
And then, I thought, jeez,
if I could ever come upon
somebody who's in the
gold business--
and you know, he might give me
a big honking crystal of
face-centered cubic metal
called gold--
which broke $1,000 an ounce
yesterday, but--
anyways, if you're out there,
and you're watching these
lectures, I'm here.
It's 8201, and you can
see any anytime.
My assistant's name is Hillary,
she'll take the call.
All right.
So let's go back
to the slides.
Dave, could we cut to
the slides, please?
Thanks.
All right.
So now--
oh, I'm going to show
you a few others.
Remember, here's the idea, that
we're looking down to the
elemental level.
So if you look on your periodic
table, it says 10,
you see, 10, it's supposed
to be tetragonal.
So here's a crystal of 10.
Dave, cut back, please.
We're going to go back and
forth today a lot.
There's a piece of ten 10.
So you might look at it
and say, gee, that
looks kind of cubic.
But if you look carefully, the
vertical dimension is greater
than the horizontal.
In fact, it's got
a square base.
And then, this is
the tall one.
Which, if we cut back to
the slides, let's see.
And that's what tetragonal
looks like.
And we'll study all of these
in a few minutes.
These are some giant crystals
I didn't dare drag in.
This is sort of human-sized
scale.
This is balsalt, which is a
magnesium iron silicate.
It's on a coast of Iceland.
Dave, let's show them
a few more.
Here's one more, if we go
to the document camera.
This was beryllium aluminum
silicate.
This is a barrel.
And you can see, this has
got a hexagonal habit.
So something's going on at the
atomic level that's different
as we go from one crystal
structure to the other.
What else have I got here?
Here's some calcite, here's
some fluorite.
Look at this one.
This is square pyramidal
but it's ionic.
So don't give me any of
that sp3 d2 stuff.
Because it's not going
to work here.
All right.
Let's go back to the
slides, please.
So then we jump to
1781, to France.
Rene Juste-Hauy was at the
Sorbonne, and he was studying
the cleavage of calcite
crystals.
In other words, he was
taking these things
and breaking them.
So he'd go to work every
day and break things.
And he studied the shards, and
he found that the shards were
all rhombahedral.
the same shape as the
parent crystal.
No matter how small the
shards got, they
always looked like this.
He didn't end up with
cubic shards.
long slivers.
He always ended up with
rhombahedral slices.
So the other thing is that he
didn't end up with any voids.
No matter how he cut this thing,
he never got voids.
So he reasoned that this must be
the way things are packing
in three space perfectly.
So then he said, gee.
If they pack perfectly
rhombahedrally--
we all know that we can stack
boxes together perfectly,
cubes together.
So he, being a Frenchman, said,
what's the mathematical
formulation?
They were steeped in
mathematics there.
That wasn't a slur against
the French.
It's a compliment.
He said, what are the
mathematically distinct
shapes, that if we stack them
together in three space they
will fill three space
with no void?
And the answer is seven.
Seven space-filling
volume elements.
By the way, the gabled milk
carton isn't one of them.
And so he called the crystal
system, so I call seven
distinct shades of
milk cartons.
And these are the seven crystal
systems, and they're
described geometrically, and
you'll get a chance to go
through them.
The cube is one of them.
Tetragonal.
Here's the calcite,
rhombahedral.
There's barrel, hexagonal,
and so on.
The seven different ways you
can feel three space.
And this is from the archival
readings of my predecessor,
Professor Witt.
Actually, just to give your
a sense, here's the
two-dimensional analogy.
If I said to you, we're going
to open a company, and we're
going to make bathroom tile, and
we want to make it sort of
an upscale company, you know,
not everybody wants boring old
square tiles.
But definitely, I can cover two
space with square tiles by
putting them side by side,
one on top of the other.
What's another way I can fill?
I can go with rectangular
tiles.
So this dimension is different
from that dimension.
What's another way?
I can use a rhombus, right,
at 60 degrees.
Or I can use just a plain old
parallelepipede at some
arbitrary angle.
And if you go over to the Stata
Center, to the Gehry
building, take a look at
the shape that they
chose as the unit cell.
This is the repeat group, if
you like, or the unit cell,
because that's the one that's
going to be cookie cutter
replicated, side by side.
When you're putting the skin
on a building, you have to
make everything fit with
no holidays, right?
Because you don't want gaps.
what they chose was
this area element.
And all the pieces of stainless
steel are cut to
this shape.
And that's how you
make things fit.
How you take something and make
it fit around a three
dimensional object is tricky.
It's the same thing as the
clothing problem, right?
How do you take a flat piece of
cloth and make it fit the
contour of the human body?
At least, you know, in men's
clothes, you know, we've got
dimensions.
We've got sleeve length, got
waist, chest. We've got all
these numbers.
For a woman, 8.
One number?
Fashion designers don't
know crystallograpy!
If they knew crystallography,
they'd know how
to specify the shapes!
If you understand this, you can
start your own business
and make clothes that fit.
And I guarantee you, there's
a market out there for
clothes that fit.
What about this one?
Pentagon.
We're going to make pentagonal
bathroom tile.
Well, when we install these,
we're going to have to use two
different colors.
You can see this
up here, right?
This is pentagonal
bathroom tile.
It doesn't fit.
You've got all these
white spots.
So this is not a unit cell.
This is not one of the crystal
systems for two dimensional.
So this one's no good.
We better put an x through it,
in case someone fell asleep,
and wake up, and then tell
me that that's OK.
All right.
So then we move about half
a century forward, to the
turbulent year 1848,
also in France.
Auguste Bravais.
And what Bravais did, is
he said, all right.
This is just filling space.
But where are the atoms?
I haven't told you where
the atoms are, right?
You know, as far as you're
concerned, maybe there's one
atom in each of these boxes.
Or maybe there's atoms at
the corners of the box.
Or maybe there's atoms
at the corner and the
center of the box.
Where are the atoms?
I've simply told you that I
can fill three space with
boxes, or with these rectangular
boxes, and so on.
So he set out mathematically
to prove how many different
arrangements of points
there are in space.
It's sort of like saying, if I
want to tell you where all the
apples are in the orchard, I'm
going to tell you where the
trees are, and I'm going
to tell you where the
apples are on a tree.
So where do the atoms go
inside these boxes?
Turns out there's 14 different
arrangements.
And what do I mean by that?
This is a good example.
So we've already established
that the cube is a
space-filling volume element.
It's one of the seven.
But look.
If I'm one of the atoms at the
corners here, I've got six
nearest neighbors.
This is also a cube, but it's
got atoms at the corners and
an atom in the center.
You might say, well, what's
the big deal?
If you're in the atom in the
center, and you look to the
nearest neighbors, you've got
eight nearest neighbors.
Here you only have six
nearest neighbors.
So this is spatially
differentiated from this.
So what why don't
we keep going?
And by the way, the same
environment of that central
atom that's coded green is the
same environment of any of the
atoms on the corners.
They're all symmetric.
So both are cubes, but they
have different space point
environments.
And here's a third one, where
we put atoms at the corners
and atoms on each
of the faces.
So this atom on the face, you
can see, it's got one, two,
three, four atoms in
the plane, three
behind, three in front.
It's got 12 nearest neighbors.
This has got eight nearest
neighbors, this has got six
nearest neighbors.
So Bravais went through and he
said, let's take those seven
crystal systems. Let's put atoms
in distinguishable ways.
How many distinguishable ways
can we come up with atom
arrangements?
And the answer is 14.
Now, what we're going to do in
3091, is we're just going to
confine our conversation
to the cubics.
Because you use orthogonal
vectors, they're all the same
length, the mathematics
are simple, and the
principles are the same.
And by the way, boatloads
of materials are
in the cubic system.
So it's not as though we just
chose something that's
convenient but irrelevant.
So here are the different
Bravais lattices.
So you can see the cubic,
there's simple cubic,
body-centered cubic,
face-centered cubic.
With tetragonal, there
is simple tetragonal,
body-centered tetragonal.
There's no face-center
tetragonal.
If you try to make face-center
tetragonal it's degenerate,
reverts to one of the
other systems.
So these are the distinguishable
systems. And
everything, including
crystalline proteins--
if the protein crystallizes, it
forms atomic arrangements
in one of these Bravais
lattices.
Everything conforms to one of
these Bravais lattices.
And if it doesn't, it means it
lacks long-range order, in
which case it is a glass.
That's it.
So here's face-centered cubic.
You can see the placement.
But there's something that's
been simplified here.
Right now what you see is a
single atom, designated by a
hard sphere.
But at each of these lattice
points, I can put
more than one atom.
So let me show you what
I mean by that.
What I want to do, is put
different numbers of atom
arrangements at the
lattice point.
So those positions, the
distinguishable positions, are
called lattice points.
And now I want to define
the crystal structure--
the crystal structure is the
complete accounting of atomic
arrangement.
It's the complete description
of atomic arrangement.
And we don't have to go too far,
because we just have to
get the base unit, the unit
cell, and then just
repeat the unit cell.
Complete description of
atomic arrangement.
And so how we going
to go about this?
We're going to start with
a Bravais lattice.
And what is the Bravais
lattice?
The Bravais lattice is simply
a point environment.
And this will mean something to
you in about three minutes,
when I give you the rest
of the description.
So it's a set of points in
space and the basis.
And what is the basis?
The basis is the atom group
at each lattice point.
So what do we mean by that?
Well, let's look at what's
up on the board.
What's up on the board is
face-centered cubic.
So let's do all of these.
So we're going to say that the
Bravais lattice, in this case,
in face-centered cubic, FCC.
That's what this one is,
up on the board.
And we've got dots indicate
the points.
Because really, the points
are nothing.
It's a concept.
See, it's French.
It's a concept, right?
What's this?
See what I'm holding?
I'm holding a Bravais lattice.
It's just a set of points.
It's like a John Cage piece,
you know, a bunch of rests.
So if I go to the piano
and I play rests in
five four time, listen.
Isn't that great?
Man, it's fantastic.
All the different rests,
and different--
So this is a set of
lattice points.
Now I'm going to put
something on them.
You think I'm kidding.
I'm not.
All right.
Now what's the basis?
If I put a single atom, we have
what's up on the slide.
And so that's the representation
of metal.
So for example, gold is FCC,
with a single gold atom at
each lattice point.
Aluminum, copper, platinum.
These are all FCC metals.
So there's a single atom at
Bravais lattice point, and so
the crystal structure
is known as FCC.
It's the same as the
Bravais lattice.
It's called FCC.
OK.
Now, we can also put a molecule
at each lattice site.
So I'm going to put
up the FCC here.
Here's the FCC.
There's the cube, the set of
lattice points, and the
lattice points are--
I'm going to just illustrate
on the front face.
One, two, three, four, and a
fifth atom at the front face.
Now these are the points.
I could either put simple atoms
there, and the central
image there shows what happens
when you have the close-packed
arrangement, the atoms are
so big that they touch.
Or what I could do, at
each lattice point,
I could put a molecule.
So for example, I could
put methane.
I could put CH4.
A methane molecule.
Because when one of you gets
to Jupiter, and you see the
methane ice, and you go, oh.
That's FCC.
Because everybody else on the
mission hasn't taken 3091.
They don't have a clue what
they're looking at.
But you go, that's face-centered
cubic.
And they go, huh?
And this is at each
lattice site.
You see, my point is, now look,
here's the difference.
All five of these, the carbon
and the four hydrogens, sit at
this lattice site.
All five atoms sit at
It's not that the carbon goes
here, one hydrogen goes over
at one lattice site, one
hydrogen over here.
You don't have the methane
straddling the unit cell.
You have all five atoms
here, five atoms here.
At every lattice point, I
have all five atoms at
each lattice point.
So in that case, we also
have, it's FCC.
So methane ice is face-centered
cubic.
Because it's spherical.
They pack just like gold
atoms. You know, from a
distance, we can model this
as a sphere, as a point.
Or we could put an ion pair.
An example of that is sodium
and chloride, and this is
called rock salt crystal
structure.
Rock salt.
Let's look at that one.
So at each last lattice point,
I'm going to put two ions.
Not one, two.
This is taken from your text.
So you might look at this and
say, well, here's the front.
You might look at this and say,
well, isn't this kind of
like simple cubic?
Because I've got one, two,
three, four, but I've got
different atoms if I
try it that way.
See, this is taken from
a different book.
I did some highlighting on it.
So this is sodium
chloride again.
One, two, three, four, five.
With this lattice site, I put
the chloride atom and the
sodium atom.
The pair of atoms are
associated with
this lattice site.
You might say, yeah, but
this is way over here.
Doesn't matter.
I'm going to anchor all of those
to this lattice site.
To this lattice site, I'm going
to anchor this and the
sodium ion.
So this is not simple cubic.
Because if I try to call this
simple cubic, I have different
atoms at different lattice
sites, and that's a no-no.
Has to be the same.
So if I associate the pair,
chloride ion and sodium ion,
chloride ion and a sodium ion
not depicted.
It's off the diagram here.
And I put these dots at the
center of each chloride ion.
Can you see that I'm
at the face of FCC?
So that's an FCC Bravais
lattice, but it's got two
atoms, in this case, both ions,
associated with each
lattice point.
I will come to the
dogs in a second.
And now there's a last
one I can do.
And that's got two atoms,
but not an ion pair.
We're going to put
an atom pair.
Got an atom pair, and that
looks like this.
I'm going to put a carbon atom,
one carbon atom, and a
second carbon atom.
And this angle here
is 109 degrees.
And I'm going to put this pair
of carbon atoms together, and
when I do that, and I replicate
that through FCC, I
end up with diamond cubic.
And I'll show you a
three-dimensional example of
that next day.
So just bear in mind that if you
have an ion pair, you end
up with rock salt.
If I show you this pair,
this is due to the sp3
hybridization.
And so examples of this one
are diamond, not graphite,
just diamond, silicon--
so everything that I've shown
you about single crystals, and
intrinsic and extrinsic
semiconduction, is diamond
cubic crystal structure.
But it's not one of the
Bravais lattices.
It's an FCC Bravais
lattice with two
atoms per lattice site.
That's diamond cubic
crystal structure.
But it extends to
two dimensions.
So here's an Escher print.
It's got all these dogs.
In two dimensions, what's the
crystal structure here?
Well, there's no such thing
as body-centered cubic.
There's no third dimension
in two dimensions.
So you've only got simple cubic
or face-centered cubic.
So what do we have here?
Well, you see, you've
got a problem.
Because the black dogs are
facing the opposite direction
of the white dogs.
So you can't go one, two,
three, four, and make
anything that way.
So instead, I put dots on the,
I don't know what you call
this part of the dog.
I don't know.
This part of the dog.
The leg?
Whatever you call this thing.
Yeah.
You put it on the same
spot of the dog--
maybe I should have used his
eye, I know how to call it.
Anyway.
So I put these things
up, right?
And that means that if I
associate the four dogs with
this point, the two dogs facing
the right, and these
two dogs facing the left.
So these four dogs are
associated with
this lattice site.
Then I move up here, and I've
got the same thing.
One, two, three four.
Two dogs facing right,
two dogs facing left.
So that means I've got a simple
cubic bravais lattice,
and the basis is four dogs.
Four dogs as my basis.
And with that combination of a
simple cubic lattice and four
dogs is the basis, I can make
the entire structure.
That's what this is all about.
That's my unit cell, that's
my repeat unit.
So there's simple cubic,
right there.
So instead of a single atom at
each corner, or these are
spheres that are touching,
we got the four dogs.
Here's another one.
Once I got the Escher, I kept
flipping through the book.
I don't know what this thing
is, but it's creepy.
Anyway.
It's wallpaper.
If it's wallpaper,
it's ordered.
If it's ordered, it's a
two-dimensional crystal.
If it's a two-dimensional
crystal, it has to conform to
one of the 14 Bravais
lattices.
So which one is it?
So I looked at this for a while,
and I took this happy
entity here, and I put
a dot in its belly.
So wherever I found one
of these, I put a dot.
and then I connected the dots,
and what do I get?
I got the rhombus.
Now, what's the basis?
That's the Bravais lattice.
What is the basis?
So I went over here and I said,
well, if I start from
this thing and I go all
the way up, I got some
tail, blue tail here.
And this thing way down
here looks like
it's missing a tail.
So if I start from this, go all
the way down to here, and
capture all of this material
in between and associate it
with that lattice point,
that can be my basis.
And then I take that set of
imagery, and I put it on top
of this, where it's centered at
about this thing's navel,
and put it around here.
You can see, the translation
is obvious there, and the
translation is obvious here.
There's the wallpaper.
So it's part of a Bravais
lattice, only in two
dimensions, you see?
This is crystallography.
That's all it is.
Crystallography.
All right.
So the next thing that we have
to do, it's kind of a little
bit boring, but you need to know
this stuff, because it's
formative for the next unit.
It's the characteristics
of cubic lattices.
Now what do I mean, the
characteristics?
I mean the geometric
characteristics.
So there's a table here that
I've taken out of your
archival reading.
If you go to the website,
there's a set of notes that
were written by my predecessor,
Professor Witt.
And if you go and look
this up, this unit on
crystallography, there's
this table.
And it shows such things as
the unit cell volume.
Well, what's the unit cell?
The unit cell is this cookie
cutter cube that's the repeat
unit, and it has a dimension
here called a, which is the
lattice constant.
It's the size of the box.
So what's the volume
of the unit cell
Well, duh, it's a cubed.
That's obvious, all right?
Doesn't matter whether it's
simple cubic, face-centered
cubic, body centered cubic.
How many lattice points
per unit cell?
Well, that's-- how many atoms
do I get per unit cell?
If you look at this, you
say, well gee, it's--
you know, if you've got the
simple cubic, you've got them
at the eight corners, so
it's eight, right?
Well, no, because each atom on
the corner is inside this
cell, but it's also inside the
neighboring cell, and it's
inside each of the eight
neighboring cells.
So I have eight times
one eighth.
So the total amount of atom
within the cube is only one.
That's why you've got to go
through this derivation.
So here's an example for
face-centered cubic.
You see the corners, one,
two, three, four?
There's eight of those.
Eight times one eighth is one.
And then you've got these atoms
on the face, and there's
one, two, three, four,
five, six, right?
Six faces.
But each of these atoms
on the face is only
half inside the cube.
The other half is in
the other cube.
So I got six times one half is
three, and that gives me four.
So that's how you go through,
and figure out
what's going on.
And then you can look at things
like nearest neighbor
distance, and what's the
relationship between the
radius, if you're looking
at hard sphere packing.
So here's a good example.
Here's the hard sphere
packing model.
So I've got atoms all
the same size, and
they're packed to touch.
And they're packed to touch so
that in the end, I end up with
a face centered cubic
arrangement.
And so what's the relationship
between the radius and the
lattice constant?
And it's just simple
trigonometry, right?
4r equals 2a squared, and you go
through it, and that's how
you end up with all
these formulas.
So that's what going on.
All right.
So I think we're going to move
to the last five minutes here.
So just a couple of comments.
Today we played music
when you came in.
It was Burning Down the House.
An old piece by Talking Heads.
Why was I playing Burning
Down the House?
Well, I want you to study
this painting.
This is a painting by Georges
Braques, from 1908, And it's
called The Houses at L'estac,
or if I speak Canadian, The
Houses at L'estac.
And you see the thing
about these houses?
You see the ones in the
background have better
definitions than the ones
in the foreground?
And the ones in the foreground
are all distorted, and kind of
falling over?
Well, when this was exhibited
at the Salon, on the critics
lambasted it.
They said, this thing is
absolutely childish.
And one of the critics
said, this isn't
a painting of houses.
This is nothing but
a stack of cubes.
And from this painting, and that
negative comment, came
the term cubism.
And so the entire movement of
cubism comes from this.
And since we're studying the
properties of cubic crystals,
I thought the connection
was pretty tight.
And that's why I chose
that piece.
Don't go anywhere yet.
We still have a couple
of minutes.
It's not better out there
than it is in
here, I guarantee you.
All right.
So now I want to show you
one of the properties.
Why do we care about atomic
arrangement Suppose some of
you are interested
in fiberoptics.
One of the things you have to
do in fiberoptics is make
junctures, because you can't run
a cable 100 miles without
making some junctures.
Well, atomic arrangement
reflects microscopic
properties.
And one of the properties that
you can have in a crystal is
something called birefringence,
depending on
the atomic arrangement.
So what happens is if you have
a ray that comes in from the
left here, it splits into two.
And that's no good, in
certain instances.
In other instances, if you want
a beam splitter, you want
something birefringent.
So look at all these crystals.
Quartz is birefringent.
Ice is.
You've seen it.
Calcite is birefringent.
What do I mean by that?
Well, Dave, can we cut to
the document camera?
Right.
So here's a here's
a crystal of--
well, this is my handwriting.
It's beautiful.
Let's write-- here's more.
Isn't that beautiful?
OK, enough about me.
Now let's--
All right.
So this is birefringent.
But what happens if
we rotate it?
We can change the degree.
And if we're really clever, and
we get it onto the optical
axis, we can actually get these
things to superimpose.
Here's a piece of cryolite.
This is the stuff they
make aluminum out of.
They dissolve aluminum in it.
And you can see that, see, I
loaned it to somebody, and
they dropped it.
And when they dropped
it, they damaged it.
That's what happens.
Look, it's all crunched
up there.
But anyway, I don't want
to get into that.
But so you can see, if we turn
this and we get it right on
the optical axis, we can
actually make these things
line up sometimes.
Anyway.
So you can see the property
of birefringence.
OK.
Let's go back to documents,
Dave. One more thing.
Last thing I want to show you.
You know gold.
Gold looks like this.
It's yellow, right?
Well, depending on how you, you
know, those of you have
seen certain wedding bands know
that if you want to make
a white gold, you add
nickel to it.
And once the nickel content gets
above a certain level,
the gold looks white.
In other words, just metallic
reflective.
In Eastern Europe, it was common
to add high levels of
copper, in which case, you get a
beautiful rose-colored gold,
or pink gold.
I'm going to show you
some blue gold.
This isn't a joke.
This is 14 karat.
It's 40 plus percent
by weight gold, and
the balance is indium.
And when you add indium
to gold, you get blue.
Document camera, please.
Just so that you remember.
OK.
That's gold.
This is gold foil.
Rutherford, et cetera,
et cetera.
You know, this is yellow gold.
Ho-hum.
This is white gold.
Same deal, but with
some nickel.
Now it's reflecting off
of the yellow gold.
Boy, there's a lot of
yellow in here.
Where's that coming from?
It's hard to tell.
All right.
Now Let's look at
some blue gold.
This is blue.
So, but it's brittle.
So you know, what are you going
to do with something
that's brittle?
You can't shape it.
So I have an idea.
So here's my idea.
See, what we do is--
see this?
We do, instead of this,
we put this.
We drill a hole in it, we put
hands on it, we sell it for a
lot of money.
It's blue gold.
It's blue karat gold.
What you can do if you
understand crystallography.
All right, get out of here.
I'll see you on Friday.